Traduttore: Peggy-Anne Berthier
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Qualche anno fa,
lavoravo in una grande, e famosa,
Università di ricerca.
E nel mio dipartimento,
come in tutti i dipartimenti,
c’era un responsabile della sicurezza
che aveva il compito di testare,
una volta al mese,
il sistema di allarme
che faceva un grandissimo rumore.
Un giorno, come forse avrete intuito,
c'era un incendio vero.
E allora, il responsabile della sicurezza
girava per tutti gli uffici,
a partire dall'ultimo piano
per essere sicuro
che nessuno rimanesse dentro.
Apre una porta e c'era un collega
con le mani sulle orecchie:
“Lasciami lavorare! Lasciami lavorare!”
Ecco, questo collega, forse,
aveva preso il sacro fuoco per la scienza,
un po' troppo letteralmente.
Però, forse, gli scienziati
sono proprio le persone
a cui più si prescrive
questa frase famosa di Primo Levi,
[e] quest'anno ricorrono
i 100 anni della nascita,
per cui: "L’amare il proprio lavoro
costituisce l’approssimazione
più concreta alla felicità sulla terra".
Gli scienziati,
come abbiamo sentito anche oggi,
molto intensamente,
hanno spesso una vera e propria vocazione
per il proprio lavoro.
Un lavoro che a volte è oscuro,
un lavoro che non necessariamente
va sui giornali
o da grandi gratificazioni.
E anche quando queste avvengono,
vengono considerate, spesso,
come una cosa normale,
che succede e poi passa.
Sempre in quella grande Università,
il giorno che Christopher Pissarides
vinse il Premio Nobel per l'economia,
era lì a mensa insieme a noi in fila
e nessuno l'ha fatto
neanche passare avanti.
Un altro italiano, 500 anni fa,
iniziava a riflettere -
qualcosa di più di 500 anni fa,
perché quest'anno sono
i 500 anni dalla sua morte,
iniziava a riflettere
sul metodo scientifico.
Ed è forse qualcosa
di molto italiano, questo.
È un genio particolare,
che univa doti da inventore,
doti di grande artista.
Ma anche iniziava a riflettere
su cosa significasse la scienza.
E quindi, lui diceva,
con questa frase famosa,
che "Si può considerare una scienza umana
solo quella che può essere
dimostrata matematicamente".
Ecco, oggi, questa è una frase
che può essere dibattuta aspramente
in dipartimenti di scienze sociali,
e io stesso tendo a non essere
d'accordo con questa frase.
Ma come si fa a dire,
non sei d'accordo con Leonardo?
E questa, però, è una delle grandi lezioni
che la scienza ci dà ogni giorno,
perché non si è d'accordo,
o non d'accordo, con una persona,
ma con un concetto, con un'idea.
E proprio la possibilità
di non essere d'accordo
è quello che ci fa andare avanti.
Allora, forse, qualcuno al posto mio,
adesso direbbe che la scienza
è "Made in Italy"
perché 500 anni fa,
Leonardo pensava questa frase.
Ed è una frase che però io non dirò,
perché se proprio
dovessimo trovare un luogo,
allora forse, dovremmo andare a sentire
quello che ci diceva
il grande filosofo tedesco,
che vedeva l'Europa
come un leone affamato,
come un continente
sempre teso ad andare avanti.
E in effetti, l'Europa ha cambiato
il mondo tante volte, e a volte male,
e quando l'ha cambiato in bene
è stato spesso, grazie alla scienza.
E allora, è vero
che il "Made in Italy" è scienza,
così come il "Made in France",
il "Made in United Kingdom",
il "Made in Germany", eccetera eccetera.
Però, se ripensiamo allora,
a cosa successe 100 anni dopo Leonardo.
Abbiamo l’inizio della scienza moderna
con Newton e Galilei,
che naturalmente era italiano.
Allora, siccome noi stiamo costruendo
un nuovo centro di ricerca in Italia,
mi piace pensare a questo carattere.
E senza citare le centinaia
e migliaia di scienziati
che lavorano e che hanno lavorato,
mi piace citarne soltanto due.
Ricordarne due,
per ricordarli tutti insieme.
Rita Levi Montalcini e Fabiola Gianotti,
famosissime scienziate
che con i loro studi,
come tutti gli scienziati,
cambiano la vita
di tutti noi, ogni giorno.
Io, per lavoro, ho avuto la fortuna
di girare molto il mondo,
negli ultimi anni.
E gli italiani sono sempre riconosciuti
come scienziati attenti e curiosi.
Io cercavo, in questi incontri, di capire
se ci fosse qualcosa di tipico,
qualche ingrediente segreto.
E me lo disse il capo americano
di una grandissima multinazionale,
una delle aziende più grandi del mondo,
che aveva appena aperto in Italia
un nuovo stabilimento
per produrre l'ultimo suo ritrovato,
l'ultimo prodotto
da distribuire sul mercato.
Ero curioso, e gli ho chiesto:
ma perché, tra le decine di paesi
in cui voi siete,
avete scelto di aprire questo stabilimento
proprio in Italia,
e non in un altro paese?
E lui mi rispose:
perché vedi, questo nuovo prodotto -
La sua produzione
genererà problemi inaspettati.
E tra tutti gli operai,
gli italiani sono quelli
che hanno la caratteristica
di sapere risolvere problemi inaspettati.
Ecco, allora [che] fondare
un nuovo centro di ricerca in Italia
è forse una delle cose
più tradizionali e tipiche
che uno possa fare in questo paese.
Con un'altra, però, lezione
che ci viene proprio
da queste due scienziate.
O dai tantissimi altri scienziati.
Perché ricordiamoci
che ci sono pochi nomi noti,
ma centinaia di migliaia di scienziati
che fanno esattamente lo stesso lavoro,
e non è meno importante.
Perché ognuno di noi può vedere lontano,
perché sta sulle spalle
dei giganti che ci hanno preceduto.
Un bambino, oggi, ha più
nozioni scientifiche di Leonardo,
perché è su quelle alte spalle.
Allora, quello che conta,
non è tanto il luogo in cui si sta,
ma la circolarità
che si contribuisce a generare.
E il numero di idee che si contribuiscono
a fare andare e tornare.
E quindi, non tanto
la nazionalità, ma dove si sta.
Perché gli scienziati, alla fine, vanno
dove li porta il cuore
delle loro ricerche,
dove hanno i loro interessi.
E quindi, [è] con queste due sfide,
quella di compiere un passo tradizionale,
di una cosa che in Italia
si fa da 500 anni,
ovvero la sfida della scienza più moderna,
e la seconda sfida,
di aumentare la circolarità
di scambio di idee,
di scienziati e di persone,
che stiamo costruendo
Human Technopole a Milano.
Adesso siamo pochi, siamo una ventina;
ma stiamo crescendo
e cresceremo molto.
Ci siamo posti la nostra missione,
che è forse l’originaria missione
che è venuta in mente
al primo essere umano
che ha potuto formulare
un pensiero curioso:
Come fare a proteggere la nostra vita?
Come fare a migliorare la nostra vita?
E mi hanno spiegato,
perché io mi occupo della governance
di questo centro che stiamo fondando,
che la salute e l'invecchiamento
degli esseri umani dipendono:
da fattori intrinseci, da genomica;
e da fattori estrinseci,
dal nostro stile di vita,
cosa mangiamo, come ci comportiamo.
Ma la combinazione di questi due aspetti
varia da persona a persona.
E allora, la sfida è quella
di arrivare, per questa ragione,
a cure sempre più personalizzate
e a prevenzioni sempre più personalizzate,
per le quali sono necessarie
un insieme di discipline
molto diverse tra loro:
genomica, clinica di base,
diagnostica avanzata, neuroscienze,
biologia molecolare,
biologia strutturale, ingegneria,
per l'analisi di grandi masse di dati,
e per l'elaborazione di nuovi algoritmi
di Intelligenza Artificiale
necessari a processare
le enormi quantità di dati
che verranno generate
dai sequenziamenti del genoma.
E quindi, questo è il progetto
a cui stiamo lavorando,
che quando sarà completo,
tra quattro, cinque, sei anni al massimo,
comprenderà oltre 1200 scienziati,
30.000 metri quadrati,
grandi infrastrutture scientifiche
di ultimissima generazione.
Con l'obiettivo, il desiderio
e la missione chiara
di raggiungere
quattro principali obiettivi.
Il primo, naturalmente,
quello scientifico,
è quello di avere una struttura
che sia un hub, un alveare,
un luogo dove si entra, si esce,
c’è un continuo scambio con l'esterno.
Per fare un esempio,
noi avremo delle tecnologie
di ultimissima generazione
che verranno usate in parte
dai nostri scienziati di Human Technopole,
e in parte dagli scienziati
del resto della ricerca italiana
che potranno accedervi.
E non soltanto, naturalmente, italiana.
Secondo, un hub che servirà
a migliorare la qualità delle cure
del sistema sanitario nazionale,
innanzitutto italiano,
ma anche con le ricerche
che verranno fatte
su come questo tipo di cure
possono influenzare
la sostenibilità, nel tempo,
del sistema sanitario,
e anche contribuire alla sostenibilità
dei sistemi sanitari pubblici,
che sono forse uno
dei cuori più importanti
della civiltà del nostro continente.
Terzo, essere in grado
di dialogare costantemente
con l'industria e con la parte economica,
che si occupa di scienze della vita
dei grandi settori industriali,
dalla farmacia alle biotech.
Perché sappiamo che,
senza l'industrializzazione
che l'industria privata riesce a generare,
le scoperte non potranno arrivare
nelle case di tutte le persone
che ne hanno bisogno.
Quarto, e infine,
questa è un'immagine di Palazzo Italia
la sera, mentre stiamo lavorando,
perché un paio di questi piani
già funzionano ed esistono.
Human Technopole vuole essere, anche,
un ulteriore ponte di rafforzamento
tra la scienza e la democrazia.
Perché non dobbiamo mai dimenticare
che scienza e democrazia
non sono la stessa cosa,
ma sono due fratelli gemelli,
hanno lo stesso DNA.
Pensate a quante nozioni
scientifiche voi sapete,
non perché le conoscete direttamente,
ma perché vi fidate
di chi ha fatto i conti,
di chi ve l’ha raccontato.
Sappiamo che la Terra
gira attorno al Sole,
non perché lo abbiamo visto,
ma perché ci fidiamo
di chi ce l'ha spiegato.
E ci fidiamo di chi ce l'ha spiegato
perché si diventa scienziati
con un processo trasparente,
un processo aperto.
Non c'è un dittatore che decide
chi fa lo scienziato.
E per questa ragione,
è questo che vogliamo fare
a Human Technopole:
costruire una grande autorevolezza aperta
in cui la scienza è utile
per gli scienziati
e per i non scienziati,
per gli esperti
in una materia scientifica,
e per gli esperti in un mestiere,
o in qualcos'altro.
Perché non importa quanto studiamo,
quanto tempo passiamo a studiare.
Ognuno di noi può essere esperto
soltanto di un piccolo spicchio di sapere
ed è per questo che abbiamo bisogno
gli uni degli altri.
E forse niente come la scienza
è una grande, grande opera collettiva,
un grande sforzo collettivo
di persone appassionate
del proprio lavoro.
E il lavoro degli scienziati,
e il lavoro che stiamo facendo noi
in questo momento
è in fondo la stessa cosa.
Un lavoro molto semplice,
un lavoro uguale a quello
che fanno tante altre persone.
Certo, un po’ speciale,
un po’ privilegiato.
Io mi sento molto fortunato
di lavorare a un progetto
che costruisce un pezzetto,
un pezzetto di futuro.
Un po' come quel pellegrino
che camminando incontrò tre persone,
che spaccavano grandi pietre
al sole, d'estate.
La prima ha lanciato un grido di fatica.
La seconda si lamentò al pellegrino:
“Lavoro tutta la giornata
per mantenere la mia famiglia”.
Il terzo si voltò e sorrise.
E disse, sono contento,
perché sto costruendo la mia cattedrale.
Ecco, noi non stiamo in un deserto
a costruire una cattedrale.
Al contrario, siamo
in un posto molto denso,
la Lombardia, uno spicchio d’Europa
denso di ricerca, di grandi industrie,
di grandi università e di grande storia.
Ed è il motivo per il quale,
in questo contorno,
che poi in Lombardia
siamo ottimisti di poterci riuscire.
È un’impresa, sicuramente,
molto intensa, molto faticosa
ma che ci rende molto felici.
Grazie tante.
(Applausi)